[Музика]
і ця клавіатура, коли ти Падуя, так,
Бош, я повинен сказати, що жодна дитина, названа на
курсі, майже не знав, чому б не бути
стандартом, згідно з яким для Сполето
країна була Буш, який представляє молодий
бісквіт, тепер не кокні Акоста індійський
ні, ми це практично, сер - ви будете
жувати це
[музика]
добре, хлопці, я дуже радий бачити вас, як
завжди круто знову,
і сьогодні ми продовжуємо говорити про
спорт сьогодні ми збираємося говорити про
екстремальні види спорту, тому у мене є кілька
запитання, хлопці, ви коли-небудь пробували кататися на гірських
велосипедах ні, я не маю нічого, добре, тож
, чи пробували ви коли-небудь стрибки з банджі
ні ні святі мої мрії лише сотні, але у мене
є дохід, але я маю дохід, але це для
цієї лижі я думаю, що це правильно, це все
Бенґет  стрибати так так, можливо, одного дня
все стане добре, а що щодо цього
у вас цей цей
ні, у вас немає, але ви б хотіли,
тому в моїх планах є варіанти правильні
загальні екстремальні це не про мене це,
можливо, не про вас  ти будеш фін  d
екстремальний вид спорту для вас сьогодні, можливо,
добре, а як щодо кайтсерфінгу я не
пробував, але у мене є кілька друзів, які займаються
кайтсерфінгом, які займаються кайтсерфінгом,
окей, найекстремальніший вид спорту, який
був у моєму житті у воді, це був
банан банан людина
добре, а як щодо цього, ви
коли-небудь пробували кататися на скейтборді, будь ласка, хлопці,
скажіть мені, що одного разу один раз для жарту
для якогось відео для Instagram для
відео в Instagram я спробував
скейтборд не один раз, не раз,
так, не один раз, але завжди, як це буде
закінчитись це погано закінчиться
так, не сталося ні я взагалі щасливий
це все я зрозумів я чекаю
велосипеди велосипеди що щодо цього
ти не пробував скелелазіння ні це
занадто страшно занадто страшно я виріс у
єврейська сім'я моя мама ага про
стільки людей, яких ти грала на скрипці так
добре,
а як щодо цього, ти коли-небудь
пробував літати на параплані ні ні, але
це цікаво, це цікаво, добре,
ти повинен поїхати до 30 років у Туреччині
гаразд  ай, тоді як щодо альпінізму, я
не був горами, так, я намагався розривати голову,
але без снігу, коли було
літо, ми бачили кілька екстремальних видів спорту, але
який найнезвичайніший екстремальний вид спорту
мм-хм, так як ви можете зв'язати, як ви можете
думати про якісь зв'язки  зі слів, які
ви побачите на екрані з
екстремальним видом спорту, тож перше залізо так
рег. Стайрон так добре зроблено скелі як
гори так зроблено дошки Kanoa наче
вони обидві так так,
тоді електричний генератор о, це було, так
що зрозуміло, що це таке  Я можу геніально, що
вони підключили двигун, а потім приходить
Гастон, я думаю,
щось схоже на те, що ви готуєте щось на так, так, але Іван
такса не можу я добре, тоді приходить
Німеччина, так, все пов'язано
з Німеччиною, яка приходить 2002 30 команд
добре  що це за екстремальний вид спорту, що
це у мене питання, це було лише одного разу
в 2002 році, він почався в 2002 році, о, він почався
так, так, можливо, це почалося в Німеччині, це
щось на кшталт, щоб вижити,
щоб вижити, тому що ir  на скелях
електричний генератор так, зупинися, просто о так,
але тридцять команд так, добре, я
не заслуговую ніяких відхилень
і там у вас є
право найму, і ви можете зробити це в
квартирі або десь ще добре, давайте
прочитаємо текст про це, тож давайте прочитаємо
статтю про незвичайний вид спорту, і це
насправді екстремальне прасування, добре, хлопці
, будь ласка, слідкуйте за мною в читанні і
що  Для діяльності потрібні біг і
футбол, звичайно, синхронне плавання,
ймовірно, бальні танці, можливо, гра в
карти, ймовірно, не садівництво, безумовно,
не більшість людей вважає, що спорт має
поєднувати фізичну активність і
змагання, якщо ми використовуємо це визначення,
то крайня іронія - це спорт,
що є крайньою іронією, екстремальне прасування
натискання одягають нас у дуже важких
місцях іронії повинні виконувати свої доручення,
наймаючи дошки та зморшкувату пральну дотепність  h
їх на місце змагань деякі
іронії беруть електричні генератори інші
б'ють свої доручення на gastos
конкуренти отримують більше балів за
складність розташування, однак
якість прасування важлива для
кожного предмета має бути добре натиснутий крайні
іронії змагаються в деяких дивовижних місцях
учасники, поки вони
лазять на скелі, піднімаються на гори та
лазять на дерева, вони прасують шум на
спинах корів і навіть під водою одна
команда, яку я орендую, перебуваючи на автомобілі
в Атлантичному океані, цей порт не
жарт,
змагалися команди з 30 країн
Перший Чемпіонат світу в Німеччині
2002 року Філ Шоу є винахідником
надзвичайної іронії, він каже, що в
усьому світі існує близько 1500 іронії, деякі команди
мають корпоративних спонсорів німецька
корпорація помста» автовиробник платить
команді шоу. Мета надзвичайної
іронії – мати  їхній вид спорту включений
в Олімпійські ігри, можливо, вони зможуть почати
використовувати свої справжні імена в той момент, коли
учасники будуть використовувати такі імена, як чай  m cool
silk and Iron Man, чому Шоу визнає, що більшість
конкурентів не хочуть, щоб люди знали,
що вони гнізда IRA, так, хлопці, так,
це хороший спорт для початку, чи у нас є
команда з України в цьому пункті, я не
впевнений у цьому  можливо, у вас є
багато вільного часу, як у мене зараз, можливо, я буду
тренуватися по всій країні, у мене багато вільного
часу, я маю почати тренуватися, я думаю, що
все це, це все про хороші фотографії,
тільки для гарних фотографій, тому лише для гарних
фотосесій і  для розваги
так, у мене є кілька запитань, спершу, у них
є змагання між тим, хто
гладить на горі Каноа, ні, ви вибираєте
місце розташування, о, але ви повинні дуже добре натиснути кнопку
закриття, щоб отримати
хороший результат, а не просто ідеальний
розташування хто переможець хто
переможець так, тому той, хто знайде
найкраще розташування, найекстремальніший,
і той, хто найкраще гладить ах, вони
повинні знайти найкраще місце, що так,
найекстремальніший зроблено
- я керую вашим найкращим так, так, так  Я роблю
все, щоб це було ідеально  зробив, хто
судить, хто судить, що, на твою думку, жінки мають
право, можливо, їхні дружини я не знаю, чому
вони не хочуть, щоб люди знали, що
є чесні я не знаю, чи хотів би ви
знати, що це секрет, який я
хочу  я хочу, щоб усі знали, давайте
виконаємо вправу над текстом, щоб ви
отримали речення, і ви повинні вирішити
, правдиві вони чи хибні, ви можете
по черзі, тому перше, що письменник
вважає, що спорт має бути
небезпечним, це правда, правда  тому письменник
вважає, що всі духи мають бути
небезпечними.
false
це правильно, екстремальне прасування – це дуже
старий вид спорту.
ays десь за межами, так що
це правда так, це правильно, наступне
деякі компанії спонсорують команди екстремального прасування
я не знаю, я не пам'ятаю
цього в тексті, але я думаю, що це цілком
логічно так, так, добре, а остання -
надзвичайна іронія  Я не люблю, щоб люди знали
їхні імена
так, це правда, і вони
псевдоніми правильно так так добре круто шовкові
цитати cool silk або Iron Man I Румунія
добре, хлопці, ви добре впоралися з нашим завданням читання,
давайте мати граматику,
щоб представити досконалу таку можливість  ви
використовували у запитаннях і відповідях на
початку уроку, тому теперішнє
досконале розповідає нам про минуле, а
теперішнє подивіться на приклад посмішка
ви закінчили ви досягли цього
добре, ми використовуємо його, коли бачимо, що щось
відбувається в  минуле, але маючи
результат у теперішньому, подивіться на
приклад. Я купив кілька подарунків, і
вона має багато подарунків добре, як
відформатувати, ви можете побачити формулу, тому вам
потрібно have та має як допоміжне дієслово
та pas  Частка t для
їхніх правильних дієслів є закінченням IDI,
а для неправильних – третім
стовпцем таблиці неправильних
дієслів, тому для позитивних тверджень, які вам
потрібні, I will your day or Kate Tom dogs
whatever have then have та третя
форма  дієслово, наприклад gun for he she it
we need has і знову частина
форми дієслова минулого
часу подивіться на схему, тому ще раз
це дія в минулому, але
з результатом до теперішнього часу добре для
заперечний вам не потрібно, і ви ставите його
після допоміжного дієслова, наприклад,
я не пішов або він не пішов, ви можете
використовувати повну форму і коротку форму, щоб
добре, а для запитальних або
запитань ми маємо поставити здоров'я або
здоров'я  наприклад, початок, наприклад,
ми пройшли, і коротка
відповідь: так я маю чи ні я не маю так він є
чи ні, він не
добре, давайте трохи потренуємося, візьмемо три
хвилини, щоб заповнити прогалини, а потім
ми"  Я перевірю відповіді
[Музика]
[Му
так, хлопці, ви готові це
зробити так, добре, так, хто хоче
почати, я можу добре, вона написала
мені листа, вона написала мені листа
, це правильно вона
третя форма добре,
команда виграла матч так, ви можете
сказати, що команда виграла, тому що
в команді багато людей, або ви можете сказати
також, що команда має, тому що це одна
команда, давайте використаємо команду як одну,
а ви  можна сказати, що команда виграла лише той матч,
який насправді буде темою
наступного уроку, але серед інших
людей добре, тож наступний ми
ще не закінчили нашу роботу так, ми не
закінчили нашу роботу, ви використовуєте коротку форму,
але  повна форма також можлива,
тому наступна форма так,
чому ви заплатили рахунок так, чому
ви заплатили рахунок так добре,
поїзд відправився, поїзд відправився
це правильно, він не визнав свою
помилку так, він не усвідомив їх
життя зрозумів, що це правильно, останнє, що
Сандра втратила сумку
так  Сандра втратила спину, тому хлопці
знають, що ви чудово попрацювали під час цього
уроку, ми можемо зіграти. Я хочу, щоб ви використали
свої грязьові милі під час уроку,
підготуйте свої мобільні, сину, користуйтеся так,
хлопці, вам потрібно перейти за посиланням, яке
ви бачите на сайті  екран, щоб Dabba Dabba
Dabba dot Kahoot eat або ви можете
завантажити програму, але не зараз, і
введіть в гру код гри або ігровий
пін-код, тож, будь ласка, введіть ігровий
pin так, а потім введіть свій псевдонім
з'єднання псевдонім так
грубо добре один раз  знову добре, іди о так,
добре, і давайте розпочнемо нашу гру, чи
варто робити
О, готуйтеся, щоб у вас були
запитання на екрані, і вам
доведеться це зробити дуже швидко, насправді,
тому питання у нас немає запитання,
питання так, що ви намалювали  так що
виберіть і натисніть правильний заповнений привіт,
щоб правильна відповідь була як художник,
це було питання питання добре, тож давайте
подивимося на цей суд так що добре, нуль, зараз
добре, другий, так що це
питання, а ось а  nswers так хто
був першим це був цей суд так
круто так твій рот
мене теж так що Кріс ще раз
так так зараз помічає ой добре
так це те саме я довго я не був що
про цей
ні це був я привіт  Тож чи твій батько коли-
небудь був слоном, але не мав свого
батька, то покажіть мені, будь ласка, свій екран,
чому він червоний, так, тому що начос я намагався зробити
це так швидко, можливо, правильно, і це
дійсно так, так, так, так,
я готова,
так що Яна  Зумая завантажився, це правильно, але я
був повільнішим, я не знаю чому добре, але
все одно ти в першому місці, і ти все
ще гориш  правильно ви
, хлопці, добре, наступний,
зелений протягом багатьох років, це правильно,
хлопці, так що ви сьогодні всі деякі діти
добре, так скільки правильних відповідей
поспіль усі вони ні ні, ні, шість, шість
поспіль,
перший мм-  хм добре ще один ой чому так
все правильно
так що квадрат неможливо перемогти
вас і наступного s  o 50/50 так, мої
очі, де я маю рацію Сподіваюся, що у мене
є шанс
добре останній останній
о так, чи готові ви до остаточного
рахунку так,
хлопці, хто, на вашу думку, є переможцем,
о, добре, хлопці  Я був як в американському
фільмі так було легко
, це було не дуже важко, але було
цікаво,
так, було цікаво, тому що у
нас хороший конкурс, і ви користуєтеся своїми
мобільними телефонами на уроці так,
все можливо в
нашій школі, тому хлопці  Слідкуйте за оновленнями та
побачимось наступного разу
[Музика]
Дора, що був твоїм шпигуном, я маю на увазі, що я
не можу втратити підпис під спамною
ніччю, коли ти вночі я б заклав ще одного
Чічібу їй у мінімальній школі,
яка енергія для націоналізації
Ньюпорта Рахмана  Ольга Нова палац немає
належного лайна мобільність Сахалін додаткові
гроші зі Спорто йохим Шара
нас-турція
качає і Реба так, вікторина прийняти що
ми бачимо, ми ходимо був я все ще дійсний
будь-який з повністю, хоча також просто дебати,
тому moosa' виграв трофей  з Disney це
завзятий з багатьма крутими це масивна
ракета Como boys він схопив snoot
напруга меню отримати його хвилини це Роберто
має мінімальну кількість заліза екстремальне залізо екстремальне
прасування екстремальне залізо екстремальний додатковий грудний ящик
без єдиної військової дії, інакше Джанна
надала мені власну повільну латиноамериканську тревор
прасад  додаткові гроші Mr.  drebber
проклятий липкий сенс спорт о, звичайно, Тревору
19, я буду додаткові гроші, Mr.  e Том макаронна
вода h-he trebush a robot root of a
person
[Music]
you